I left something in my vehicle. I'll be right back. I just I
just parked I parked my vehicle outside. I don't remember where
I parked my vehicle. I love vehicles. Love fast vehicles. I'm
a big vehicle person. Said nobody ever. He's so close. He's so
close to breaking and laughing right here. He is so close. He
is so close. He's trying so hard. He is like biting his tongue,
trying his hardest not to smile or laugh this. You know exactly
what you're doing, Piers. No, she doesn't have a P at all. That's
absurd for you to say. Regrone has a No, he does not have a He's
going to get as much of this on camera as he can. >> Regrone
has a I'm sorry. [music]
>> Incredibly pedantic conversation, but we did get this
Willy Mack video that dropped. [music] >> I did want to
watch it possibly.
>> Uh, by the way, I am totally transforming this this
Yeah, we're going to create, you know, it's going to be transformative
content. Okay, we are not maliciously siphoning views. We are
obviously. Okay,
do not want to do do not want to risk a Caseyron type situation.
Okay,
Candace Owens is unironically evil, manipulation, lies, and debunk.
>> Nothing is sacred and that everything is going to be
debated. I'm certainly not the joke police, but Candace Owens,
who has marketed herself as Charlie Kirk's best friend, has done
nothing but grifter his murder within 24 hours after he passed.
>> Oh, this is way too fast. She posted to my friend Charlie
Kirk and she'd end the video saying she feels heard >> a
lot of paint right now and I love you Charlie and you know wait
I don't think anybody really accuses her of grifting like as
in like faking being upset that he was dead
I don't think so >> yeah I'll see you when I when I'll
see you I love you very much >> this went on to be our
most popular live stream ever this will lead to the next 3 months
being full of non-stop live streams coming up baseless conspiracy
theories about who Charlie first. It was that people at Charlie
Kirk's own company Turning Point betrayed him. >> Like
I alluded to last week and which I will double down on now.
I believe that people within that company betrayed >> Now
what's her evidence of this? Well, it's that she saw it in a
dream. I'm
>> I assume you were referencing Case John taking money
from Willie Mack, but not just but just in case not. Willie Mack
lost. Wait, he took money FROM WILLY M. OH, NO. I did see this.
It's kind of funny that that his Casey Trump video got revenue
hit. That is pretty funny, actually.
That's pretty funny.
I assume he can just cut that out. It's probably not even an
issue, right? He could almost certainly just cut that out and
not be sharing the revenue anymore. >> It's that stupid.
>> And similarly, like I just said, had a vivid dream this
weekend and Charlie
>> Hey yo, >> came to me and he told me that he was
betrayed. And so for me, you don't have to believe that, but
I do believe that it was the immediate sense I got actually.
And I
>> forgot why do we hate Willie Mack? Oh, I dislike Willie
Mack because he's a he lies about me and he's a totally disingenuous.
I I'm not going to relitigate it again. >> I don't know
who exactly it is that betrayed him. But I also felt in the >> dishonest,
not very um what would you say? Not very meticulous in his work,
like very lazy about his job a lot of the time. Our Willy's our
views on Willy's vids dropping off. I assume all of his Hassan
vids would be good. Hassan is bad is very very very profitable.
Um 100,000 views on a Hassan video here. 100,000 views on a H3
video here. 150,000 views on the Misk video. 252 227. Uh no,
I think his views are pretty
This this might have been some of the Idubbbz H3 stuff. Never
mind. That's 400,000. But that seems like an uptick. I thought
he was about 150 100 to 200,000 per video was like his sweet
spot before. It does seem like he was hitting some higher numbers
about a year ago
and that it maybe he's falling off a little bit. Uh oh, maybe
he's falling off a decent amount. I ah man, I should just check
social blade. Let me check. Let me check social blade. That'll
that'll be the true
I don't think I don't think this is like bad. I think it's about
on par for where he's he usually is. Eh, like he was better.
2023 had sections of 2024 that were a little better. It's like
down a little bit. It's not really down a lot. Probably, especially
if you consider he got married this year.
Certainly not down where it needs to be, where it should be.
Certainly far too high
at this point, okay? But
don't worry. >> That it is soon going to be revealed. That
it's actually inevitable that it is going to be revealed. That
there is nothing and no one that is going to stop the truth from
coming out. and it is going to have international consequences.
[snorts] Take that to the bank. Quote me on that. >> Yeah,
we're still waiting on that. This is all based off of her womanly
>> Women tend to have a stronger intuition about people.
I would say >> then suddenly everyone is involved. >> Honestly,
with the Candace thing, it's really just more an indictment of
humanity than it is of Candace. Candace is like, can you even
say she's lying when she outright tells you I base it on a dream
and my intuition?
Can you really say she's like outright lying?
Charlie came to me came to me in a dream and said he he was betrayed.
He was betrayed by the people at Turning Point. Can you really
say that? I mean, you can because she also lied a lot. But even
so, it's like she kind of told you all the things you needed
to know to make a good decision on whether or not to participate
in that content.
She is not true. No, she is not true. >> The US federal
government is covering it up. If you were going to bring me to
the argument that this truly was a miracle, it probably would
not. >> Also, I thought she blamed Israel within like a
week. Why aren't we I thought she blamed Israel even before Turning
Point that it was like Israel and Turning Point essentially at
the same time >> in the midst of a circumstance where the
feds are lying, right? That that is like not now, right? >> Israel
is involved because Ben Shapiro said Candace should be condemned.
Ben only care. >> What is the date on that?
Ben only cares about Israel's interests. Real Candace. Oh, what
is this tweet? This is December 18th, 2025. >> Cares about
Israel's interests. So, Israel is involved.
>> I'm pretty sure. Wait, I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
she said Israel was involved way before that, though. That's
like
two weeks ago. She was talking about Israel being involved like
months before that. Then it's France. >> I can tell you
the feds are not doing that because I was the one who said I
had the information about the French Foreign Legion being on
the ground with David
line. He's just jumping around. >> The feds have not reached
out to me. >> It's because you're crazy. She blames France
partially because she thinks the first lady has a >> and
I think you has a I really want you to know
>> Mcronone has a she thinks she's the main character.
She's like I found Egyptian planes. Isn't it suspicious the government
isn't reaching out to me about this? As soon as some podcaster
was like, "Hey, I found Egyptian planes." And they're being kind
of shady. I would be like, "Whoa,
that is
>> She just said she didn't find them. >> Are we
What's up with the Egyptian >> It's like, "Wow, everybody,
Charlie,
>> He's like not categorizing his own clips correctly.
I'm probably being pedantic because it's Willie, but
he's he's like kind of not even characterizing his own clips
effectively. >> It's Tyler Robinson." Like even if you
are somebody who is on the side of uh those who do believe that
Tyler Robinson pulled the trigger one way or another,
would you ever describe what happened as quote unquote very >> Dude,
I thought Willie was going to go and sort of describe the process.
Yeah, this is how his videos always are. But like the thing that's
cool about Candace is she has an incredibly consistent Dude,
it's so funny. It's the same It's going to be the same issue
again. Candace has an incredibly consistent pattern with how
she manipulates people. And that pattern of behavior is literally
the whole story. That is the entire thing, right? Showing how
she phrases things and how she frames things to lie without being
while trying to create plausible deniability. That is what is
interesting about Candace Owens, right? That she will lie in
a way that is intentionally trying to create plausible deniability.
So later when you call her on the lie, she'll go, "I never did
that. I never said that. Listen to what I said."
That's like the entirety of what's interesting and he's Well,
I mean, maybe he'll get to it. Hold on. Maybe he'll get to it.
>> I doubt it, though. >> I got a feeling this is
going to be >> Your answer to that would be no. >> Because
you've eaten all the glue. She has zero evidence of there being
a second shooter, but she believes that over the official story.
How? I don't know. Maybe she dreamt that up, too. Remember, Candace
claims to be Charlie's closest friend. They're basically >> Our
relationship was it was real. We were brother and sister, you
know. It was we were fortified.
>> Wait, is Willie
Is Willie claiming that isn't true?
I thought I thought Charlie explicitly like always had Candace's
back essentially. There's like a lot of texts where
there's a ton of texts where they're going back and forth. They're
like best >> Our relationship was forged in fire. The fire
of politics. Well, >> beyond just them like basically being
her being like an early member of >> I knew him. I knew
Charlie, the real >> But since she's used his death to
tear down Charlie's political party, his company, his friends.
>> Do you believe Mikey McCoy had any prior knowledge of
Charlie's murder? >> Mikey's behavior is weird on that
day. >> And now his widowed wife. >> None of us
are involved in my husband's murder. Turning Point USA
myself. >> That doesn't work for me. It doesn't work for
me and it shouldn't work for you. She implies that she was worried
about getting poisoned in her meeting with Erica Kirk. >> I
did not know if they were going to be open. I didn't know what
Erica's energy was going to be like. If
>> by the way, I think,
correct me if I'm wrong, I could have sworn the the quote he
just used is actually super disingenuous because I think what
she's saying is like the story Erica told about how like, oh,
you're just messing up. There's one of two ways that that was
happening in my head. Or there's one of two ways I remember that.
Well, it's one of two clips. It's either the one where she's
saying Erica's talking about how, you know,
she's just been like a a weeping willow or sorry, a weeping willow,
a weeping widow and totally messed up. And Candace is like, "You're
the CEO. That's your job. You should be getting the message out."
That's that doesn't work for me. Your your like weepy story.
Or it's the other one where where basically Erica says, "Oh,
you know, people just didn't quite get it." And she's like, "Oh,
really? people or sorry people were like really messed up. They
didn't they didn't act correct. She's like oh yeah people just
messed up. I don't that doesn't work for me. She wasn't saying
like oh we didn't Carly that doesn't work for me. She was she
was saying there was some doubt in the stories but it's like
a little I don't know >> if it was going to >> I'll
be less pedantic from now on. Okay >> more of an argument
if there was going to be legal threats. You guys were telling
me not to drink water so I didn't drink water. Well I brought
my own water but I didn't drink that water too. She has written
this conspiracy to being the number one podcaster some weeks
above Joe Rogan. She streams to over 300,000 people some days.
Assan is the second biggest political streamer, streaming to
about 20,000 people, peaking at 45K last month.
Is not the second biggest political
Hassan might not be a top five political
Every conservative is bigger.
Like all the big conservatives are bigger or as big as Hassan,
Fuentes and Candace both bigger than Hassan right now. Both getting
more concurrents. You can argue that they're botted. Maybe. I'm
not totally sure about that.
Um, Asenold absolutely getting more viewers than Hassan. Hassan's
like at best number four. I still feel like I don't know Crowder's
numbers. I don't know a couple of the other people's numbers.
Ben Kelly's also bigger. Well, Megan Kelly's not really a streamer
necessarily,
but maybe uh maybe you would call her if Candace is a streamer,
then Megan Kelly is probably a streamer.
little bit different. I'd say Asmin Gold and Hassan are in the
same class of streamer. Nick Fentes, Megan Kelly, Candace Owens
are all in the same class of streamer as well.
>> She is 10xing the next streamer in her genre, but it's
because her streams are so exciting. She's talking about how
France is trying to kill her Fran, the government of France.
>> It feels especially urgent, right? Don't you feel a
sense of urgency right now in the wake of me having learned that
France apparently paid for my assassination? She never elaborates
on this, by the way. Also, why are you smiling? Aren't you about
to be murdered? Candace's security is my top priority. That's
why.
>> Wait,
she elaborates a ton on that. Wait, hold on. >> France
apparently paid for my
>> She never elaborates on this, by the
>> She elaborates on that a ton.
>> It's all complete. It's like total nonsense. Well, we
watched the whole thing where she talks about like that that
like Michelin that three Michelin star restaurant in France where
all of the elites go to discuss like I don't know like political
issues and
all the back room deals happening. >> Why are you smiling?
Aren't you about to be murdered? Candace's security is my top
priority. That's why she needs to protect herself from data brokers
and hackers by using Aura. Here's a redacted report of all the
news.
features
dollar one it evil court >> sponsoring this have zero logic
zero >> how would the current court case and the jury pool
be impacted if you answered about why these Egyptian
>> and the payment that was made oh did she actually discuss
the payment that was made oh I didn't know that I knew she said
she had proof of it she discussed like where it came from how
it was wired and said she had proof I didn't see her actually
discuss the proof but she discussed like the exact ways that
like it's it's her normal shotgunning things out that doesn't
really prove anything. It's her like shotgunning points out that
aren't really connected. But she did elaborate. She did give
reasons. They're just like dog planes. Why? It's a statistical
anomaly for these Egyptian planes to be surrounding Turning Point
USA faith events. You and Charlie this many times. Why? How would
that impact? And again, I I'm a gut player. It's common sense.
So, forgive me for not being elite enough and educated enough
and expert enough to understand how it would impact things. Explain
it to me like I'm not a legal expert, you know, like I don't
trust legal experts. I think they're all full >> How is
anything she said they're common sense? It's literally the opposite
of common sense. She's explaining an international operation
to a YouTuber. She's always going on about these Egyptian planes,
but she never posts evidence of anything. >> Frankly, just
me off. So, I became locked in on these Egyptian planes because
that's how I am. Okay, you keep pushing me and keep pushing me.
I will become an expert on these planes. I'll learn how to build
an Egyptian plane. And the reality is, like I said, tomorrow
I will show you how these planes tie back to Israel. >> She
never got around to this. I know, hard to imagine. It's gotten
to the point where even Alex Jones is calling her a baseless
conspiracy theorist. dealing with Candace Owens
just as soon as the whole Egyptian plane thing gets debunked
with all the facts. Now she's moved to something else. And I'm
really worried about her. I'm worried about her and her mind.
But her latest source and what she's done implicating the US
military and all this other stuff is just so damaging.
>> That's like uh the whole crazym thing from Alex Jones
of all people is just a little much. Okay, I get you want to
say you're worried about her or something, but doing the crazy
making thing as Alex Jones, that's pretty weird to me.
Even though Candace Owens is like crazy or whatever, it's just
from Alex specifically, it's like, dude, how many times have
people said that to you,
I I just feel like, do you not do you not see the overlap? Do
you not see how that could be like kind of weird kind of seen
as weird? >> When you go investigate it, it's so crazy.
And just like with the Egyptian PL, she says she has the metadata,
then publish it. And when she did publish it
and it got fact checked, it wasn't >> The closest thing
I could find to her proof about these Egyptian planes is when
she posted the flight log in a tweet saying Tyler Robinson must
have some powerful friends, implying that the people on this
plane collaborated with Tyler Robinson to do it, but her only
proof is that a plane flew out of an airport that day. At this
point, why stop at blaming just that plane? Blame every plane
to take off from the airport that day. We have reached peak schizophrenia.
She also claims that this plane's first visit to America was
on July 20th and it was at an army base in Nebraska. But if you
look at the very flight log she posted on her tweet, it shows
that the plane stopped at OMA and LMK airport. These are the
public airports of Omaha, Nebraska and Lincoln, Nebraska. Candace,
where's the military base? This is what I mean by she just says
stuff when people
wait
that maybe that's true.
I feel like I want to fact check that. That feels like something
Candace wouldn't up as badly. Normally, if she's gonna say a
fact, the way Candace actually griffs, right, is she gets the
facts that she's using. You will never catch her being like factually
She put she basically puts a bunch of like factual elements there
and then it's like drawing a constellation, right? Like the there's
literally not really anything coherent connecting them. You sort
of have like the vague shape of something there, but then you
draw the superdetailed constellation,
So she normally the stars the the facts she uses to build the
constellation to describe the pattern those are usually
Usually usually usually or if they're not she'll say it has been
reported to me that this might be happening. She won't say this
happened
usually she won't say this happened. She thought UTC was Utah
time. Universal
time. Wait what does the C stand for? I actually don't know.
I know it's universal time something.
UTC. What does UTC mean?
Coordinated coordinated universal time. Oh, it's out of order.
I see.
>> pointed out that she's wrong. She doesn't acknowledge
it. She just says it's the Zionist coming after her. >> And
I'm like, this is happening. It's like a psychological operation
because it's it's it's it's completely crazy. When you see a
media storm like this, it can only be happening because Zionists
are locking arms and going attack attack because they are by
and large control the media. They just do. Okay? One way or the
other, Zionists control the empire medias and they are scared
about something in this investigation. We've noticed that from
the very beginning. >> It's amazing. >> I don't know
about that second part, but that first part [laughter] are we
I I want Phil Willie to fact check that. Okay, Willie, can I
get your fact check on that? Do Zionists by and large control
control mainstream media? Would that be accurate to say Zionists
do control mainstream media? I want I want the fact check. >> We
live in a world where if you're caught blatantly lying like Candace
was, you could just blame Zionist and half the internet will
forgive you. Works for a
Why not Candace? >> Wait, did he fact check it? Wait, why
didn't he Why didn't he fact check it, bro? Will he just fact
check it? Just show me like vaguely the owners and CEOs of the
top five media conglomerates and just let me know like what are
their political loyalties with regards to
I'm not saying they're I'm saying that they're a Zionist for
some they they're probably Zionist for some reason. It just seems
like a a pattern. I don't know.
I'm I'm like Pepe posting. It just is the It is just is the facts.
Okay. It's one of those things. It's um like you're only really
allowed to rise to that level where you're in control of a company
where you're like the CEO or something if you are willing to
have certain opinions, right? like like honestly it's kind of
similar to basically like if you were a race realist it would
be difficult to rise to the position of CEO right they've they've
what you call it like they've uh manufactured public opinion
or they've they've shaped public opinion in such a way so that
you being anything but a Zionist is like in the corporate world
a political non-starter right like that was that for a very long
time at least in media that was the way it was
and I say They I'm saying it's
I'm trying not to just explicitly do like the anti-semitic thing.
There there are overlaps there. There there is explicit like
um I don't know like
pressure towards making Zionism the standard position for people
>> is if your common sense can only be explained by elaborate
media and global cabals operating behind the scenes. It's no
longer common sense. But it gets
>> Yeah, I was going to say that first part was true. Probably
whatever she said they were Oh, and they're like scared of her.
I don't think that >> interview took place 2 months after
Charlie's death. And by that time, Candace was already framing
herself as more trustworthy than experts. >> Why? It's
a statistical anomaly for these Egyptian planes to be surrounding
Turning Point USA faith events, you and Charlie, this many times.
Why? How would that impact? And again, I I'm a gut player. It's
common sense. So, forgive me for not being elite enough and educated
enough and expert enough to understand how it would impact things.
explain it to me like I'm not a legal expert, you know, like
I don't trust legal experts. I think they're all full >> But
when Ellie askked questions based off basic information, >> man,
[clears throat] I will say I'm looking forward to there's so
many meta narratives with Candace that are really interesting.
Like just discussing how this became so popular, how people like
value entertainment over the truth. There's like so many things
you could talk about that could be interesting. You could have
interesting angles on them. I hope Willie gets to something like
that. I hope it's not just like basically calling Candace a liar
the whole time. >> It becomes blatantly clear that Candace
doesn't know anything. Ellie asked why Candace thinks Tyler's
text messages are fake and Candace cites Discord for some >> Do
you have any proof that the messages were made up? Because that
would be easily Yeah. proven. >> Yeah, but they didn't
put timestamps on them and Discord came out and said they didn't
exist. This was supposedly text messages, not Discord messages.
It's my understanding from the indictment.
I I actually did not read that they were text messages, >> which
means she didn't even bother to read the indictment, which said
>> that is embarrassing. I didn't watch that one. That's
rough for Candace. I didn't watch that interview with that blonde
woman. Okay, that's a huge yikes that she didn't read. How could
she have missed that? There were text messages that existed.
They literally were said to be text. That's not what that means.
Wait, that's not what what means?
Like this is Yeah, we we all read this. I read this when it came
out. It's like crazy that you wouldn't know that these were texts.
They they look like text in the pictures. I'm pretty sure there's
like pictures of them with >> did not read that they were
text >> which means she didn't even bother to read the
indictment, which says text.
>> No, she said the text messages were fake, too. Before
I believe before the the Discord messages came out, she said
the text messages were fake. She literally I know for a fact
that Candace has talked about those text messages, quoted those
text messages and said that these seem fake. Nobody says vehicle.
Is that not I believe that's an explicit quote. Nobody says vehicle.
Who says vehicle? These seem fake. I'm positive she said that
about the text message >> messages. Now, there is also
Discord messages between Tyler and his friends, but Candace claims
that Discord says they're fake. >> Have messages. It's
all over. We found it on Discord. Discord is going to say that's
not true.
So, who made up these messages? >> I have no idea where
Candace is getting that they're fake from. Discord literally
provided the messages. I'm sorry for all of this. Read a message
from the suspect's account. Discord provided a copy of the message
with the confession to authorities. And then when I am >> I
believe Discord said,
uh, was it something about there being like a group of trans
people who were collaborating together? Was that the thing they
said didn't exist? You obviously have too much faith in Candace
not being a only in the like, oh, this stopped at a military
base. only in that one case. Everything else I'm pretty much
agreeing that she's lying with.
But I'm telling you why she's been able to build a following.
It's because what people will say, people will do the the just
asking questions thing. They'll go, I know this for a fact cuz
I've argued with people who really like Candace. They'll go,
"But but why did that plane stop at a military base? But why
did that plane stop at a it's literally required. It's a requirement
of her conspiratorial thinking and her broadcast that those facts
be reliable so that people have those things to just ask questions
with.
That's so maybe she's wrong in that case, but she's normally
correct on those things. It's required for the griff she does.
>> Able to track down Candace's sources. The logic is so
flimsy. >> When you say you believe that Charlie Kirk was
betrayed by someone close to him, what do you mean?
I think that in the coming weeks there's going to be a lot of
financial reports that are coming out and I first and foremost
do not believe that Tyler Robinson Charlie Kirk I want to be
very clear on that. Uh whether he was involved I think the answer
is
>> oh Sim Hoy I understand you want to do this but if you
just say the did
you would never ever be able to slow Candace Owens down or explain
to anybody like how she's successful. You would you would just
fail to deal with her at all front on all fronts.
Like if Candace was your enemy in some way, you needed to take
her out in some way. That is like in terms of rhetoric, okay?
Not anything else.
You would fail to do so. If you just think she's
that's the problem, right? You don't understand something. You
can't stop it. You can't even like really explain to others how
it works. It's like you you lack understanding.
That's all. What did you think about people like Chud and Too
Lazy to try thinking she's stupid rather than dishonest?
Um, I would say that she is Oh, is she stupid? I don't know.
She maybe she's not like super smart. I'm not totally sure,
but she is fundamentally dishonest. I do think she fundamentally
understands that she doesn't have the answers to things,
but she's found she's kind of like Trump
that she's got some patterns and whether those patterns are practiced
or ingrained, I don't know.
But I do know that it is a persistent pattern where she uses
these facts that she can't paint connections that she can't make
connections between and she will use the presence of those facts
to consistently drive a narrative without being able to actually
causally show anything.
but she will just kind of raise suspicion,
say that this is true. She won't prove it's true. She won't show
a causal relationship between any of the facts she presents and
the actual things she's complaining about, but she'll just raise
enough points kind of to to shotgun some stuff out and then go,
"Look,
it's classic conspiratorial thinking, but she's just she naturally
does it at in like real time in a way that lets her weave those
narratives." like she put that whole Charlie Kirk thing together
and like Willie already said 300,000 live viewers. Okay.
So again, I don't know. I don't know how to describe that. Stupid,
smart, dishon I I can just say that is repeatable.
Like there's a methodology there. I don't know if it's totally,
you know, conscious or subconscious, but there's a methodology
there that is repeatable and she's continuing to profit off of.
>> Yes, I think
that's obvious. Um, it's >> and your basis for saying he
didn't act alone is what? >> I don't know, maybe the weird
Fed messages that were concocted out of thin air that had no
time stamp and were written like they were were speaking in >> What
Candace is referring to is that
>> she's talking about >> Robinson said vehicle instead
of car in the text message. >> Oh, look.
I pull that off the top of the dome. The >> second term
that I want you to look for in your phone is vehicle. vehicle.
Why I mean what?
>> This is particularly funny for me because I say vehicle
all the time and people in chat get so mad at me like what the
you talk who calls it a vehicle. Are you what the [__]
So Candace goes, "Nobody calls it a vehicle." I'm like, "I call
a vehicle. I'm not a fed."
>> pops up for you. Is that something that you say? I'm
just going to go outside to my vehicle. I left something in my
vehicle. I'll be right back. I just I just parked I parked my
vehicle outside. I don't remember where I parked my vehicle.
I love vehicles. Love fast vehicles. I'm a big vehicle person,
said nobody ever. The text messages that were released yesterday
in the indictment of Tyler Robinson make perfect sense if you
don't think about them at all. Like literally, if you suspend
all reason, all rationality, then they can make perfect sense.
That's the only way. You just have to stop thinking. >> This
is it. This is her proof that the text messages are fake and
that the feds are involved in covering up Charlie's >> But
what's funny is Candace says the word vehicle all the time. >> President
gets shot in a moving vehicle in Dallas. I almost made him pull
over the vehicle. Hollywood
vehicle. >> Yeah, he just gets out of
>> Okay, hold on.
Wait.
We all know exactly why that's a totally
example to just use right there. Right. This is what I'm talking
about that this guy's so lazy. He just did a film mod search
and he just threw these in without thinking about it. Hollywood
is the vehicle. Is that using vehicle in the way that she's calling
it weird?
Talk about something being the vehicle for an idea. That is a
completely different concept than calling a car a
>> I almost made him pull over the vehicle. Hollywood is
the vehicle. He just gets out of his vehicle. Who owned a white
vehicle that was parked in the neighborhood? which >> that's
particularly funny, I think, cuz if I recognize the outfit, this
is from her doing conspiracies on Tyler
>> Was nearby where the shooter had walked. Nick lives
nearby. And >> dude, [laughter] that's crazy. She's using
the word in the same thing. The Is that the same outfit? There's
no way. No, it's not. It's not. It's a different day. But it's
the same conspiracy. >> Everyone locally had looked at
this vehicle and said that it was remarkably suspicious. and
Phil had come back to him and said, "I can help you." >> Oh,
that Tyler Robinson in the body cam footage, he actually says,
"My vehicle," like they hit my vehicle. Oh, that would be another
reason to believe it. This is completely stupid from Candace.
We laughed at Candace. It was completely
>> Just figure out more about this vehicle that was parked.
>> She can't be this stupid, dude. The proof of her being
malicious comes from her showing footage from 2022. Tyler Robinson
talking to the police after a car accident. During the discussion
with the officer that showed up, Tyler certainly refers to it
as his car, not his vehicle, because that's how most Americans,
how most English speakers refer to a car. Mom's on her way. >> Yeah,
she's got to be a minute. She's got to shuttle over from where
she's at to her car and then drive over. Gotcha.
>> His mother, >> there's no way he continues to
go on and talk about his vehicle. going to shuttle over from
her car.
>> No, it's not. I looked up the exact same video that
Candace showed, and if you watch the whole thing, Tyler says
the word vehicle just a couple of minutes >> As I get into
the intersection, he pulls. There was a vehicle in the lane.
>> Wow. It's as if people have vocabularies and use different
words sometimes. Candace showed this exact same video and then
purposely cut it off for her audience right before her point
was about to be the
>> I actually So, I don't think that's what happened. I
think Candace basically crowdsources her stuff. This isn't better,
right? This is the exact same way Willie same exact same way
Willie gets his you just crowdsource your information, right?
You don't actually go and do any deep dives to check. I don't
believe Willie deep dove on this himself. He probably just saw
it on Twitter, right?
But I like it's how he just got that Hollywood is the vehicle
thing.
She She probably didn't even watch the rest of this body cam
footage. I'm telling you, she probably didn't even watch it.
She didn't go like search it to see if her point was made correctly.
People just are really bad at that. Ken is particularly bad at
that. She probably got sent this was like, "Look, he's calling
it a car here. It's obviously fake." And it doesn't excuse it.
Excuse me. It doesn't excuse it. It just um
it's almost the same as how >> this isn't an accident.
She's being malicious. It's not a coincidence that all of her
sources are unnamed and anonymous and that no other outlet is
receiving anything. It gives her the freedom to just make stuff
up. feds are like on a computer like typing it out back and forth.
>> That's exactly what it is. The feds made up the text
messages, >> but you don't have anyone from like the FBI
telling you that or
>> Okay. [clears throat] >> Has anyone leaked to
you? >> And Tyler Robinson.
>> But has anyone said to you even off the record like,
"Yeah, we faked these." I have very strong sources everywhere
on both sides from Lance to
>> That's no, by the way, that's conspiracy theorist for
no.
No, nobody's
>> if if it was yes, >> she'd speak about it in a
totally different way, but that's just conspiracy theorist for
no >> family to federal government. And I am making the
statement that those text messages were made up and that they
did not come from Tyler Robinson. >> But she won't show
any of this evidence because it doesn't exist. She's not doing
an investigation. She's writing fanfiction. Meanwhile, she doesn't
even know what town Charlie was shot in. >> I don't know
what he means. Where is he stuck here, guys? Do you have a clue
here? I'm stuck in a rem longer. It shouldn't be long until I
can come home. Is that a typo? I should have asked you guys.
Okay, that's the that's the town. Okay.
[laughter] >> How do you not know the town? This is the
number one political streamer right now. She's worse than Hassan.
Hassan at least cites where he gets his fake news from. Candace,
meanwhile, will just start claiming that the real shooter popped
out of a hole in the ground. This episode has three and a half
million views, and in it, Candace claims the federal government
forgot something. >> Did she really do the escape hatch
conspiracy? There's no way. >> Just implying that there's
an entire underground there.
>> Yeah. Kilo, he's trying to make money. Don't you know
that Hassan is bad? Kilo, you of all people should understand
that Hassan is bad and we need to talk about Hassan in every
video. Hassan is bad. Assault is bad. Assault is bad. Assault
is bad. >> And I remember when I looked at the footage,
I felt like it was coming up. I don't know anything about ballistics.
I'm not an expert,
but if there was a hatch door nearby,
then we can assume, as we should always assume with colleges,
obviously stadiums, there's always an underground path. So, I'm
wondering if the federal government has explored the possibility
that somebody could have been under Charlie and done that while
everyone's looking around and thinking that a shot went off from
here. If that was just maybe like decoy number two and actually
Charlie was shot from beneath him, which then could maybe explain
why there was no exit wound. Again, I'm theorizing because I
have a right to I have a right to think. >> Feel free to
stop because you're bad at it. She says she needs precise footage
of Tyler Robinson pulling the trigger >> that I would say
that is um
like less bad than most of the other things she that like at
least there she's doing the like well I'm theorizing this isn't
true but I will say for her because of how she her audience is
her audience is going to run with that as true right obviously
like there's no responsibility on her part there I would never
grant that charity to anybody I considered intelligent so I'm
just saying that compared to a lot of her other lies that are
very practiced, very like obvious, very very excruciating to
sit through because of how manipulative how manipulative they
are. That's a little better. That's a little better.
Like realistically,
of course, our audience is going to take that as true when they
decide to go. Kenda says, "Charlie came to me in a dream." [laughter]
And their audience is like, "Yeah, I believe it. I believe >> To
believe that it's him, but apparently she needs no footing. believe
someone popped out of the ground like a mole and shot Charlie.
They paved the area where Charlie was shot and Candace thinks
they're hiding tunnels. >> I think that that would probably
be an interesting one for the feds to explore because within
48 hours I mean >> they definitely paved that because they
would have had to, you know, the blood would have been soaked
into the stone or something, right? I'm guessing that it would
have been difficult to pressure wash all that blood out like
once you get that volume of blood like trying to pressure wash
that out is a little difficult. No. >> Was it 48 hours
Skyler? They decided to instead pave that area, repave it. Do
we have footage of that? They paved it. And I feel like that's
was a little soon. So, I don't know if if things can be
um unpaid. I'm sure they can, but maybe exploring a tunnel network
would be a good start. >> Candace, you're literally a millionaire.
Go to the school yourself and investigate the tunnels. Now, let's
dive further into Candace's sources. dying [singing] inside.
>> Oh, this is where this is where it really comes out
is how she uses sources to lie that she will consistently just
say, "Well, it was reported to me. I have a source that says,
right, this is probably the biggest gripe I have with Candace
is how she will consistently use sources. She'll get like a literal
skitso email in the middle of the night and go, "Guys, somebody's
reported to me that this is true." And then what she'll do to
what she'll do to make sure that's real, what she did with that
Fort
Hawaka,
I can't remember the name, the fort in Arizona. What she did
with that story was she just made sure this guy was in the FBI
at some point or was in the army at some point. She just like
checked the guy's identity. Was like he was in the army 30 years
ago. Cool.
Didn't like validate any of the other elements of the story.
Was just like, "Oh, I know that this guy is a guy. So now I'm
going to take everything he says and present it to you."
Wuka.
>> Most of the time when people ask Candace for a source,
she just defers to her gut instinct, her common sense. But I
don't >> No, she doesn't. No, she doesn't. No, she doesn't.
No, she uses she uses really sources explicitly as
Tyler is on videotape. She calls it fake based on nothing and
her audience will just believe her. >> What are we to discern
from all of this? I'll tell you. I'll tell you my take on
I think the person in the maroon
that's walking is different from the person that's walking up
the stairs. It's a gut thing. Okay. I don't know. No, but I know.
Okay. I don't know. Now, >> we we understand that this
is not like something you could source, right? She's giving her
interpretation of some fact.
What? How would you source this? She She did source it. It's
the same video you're showing. That's the source. This is her
interpretation of that source
I sorry, we understand this, right? That she's not she's using
her gut, but this isn't her using a source or talking about sources
or refusing to name a source. Like that's not what this is. It's
fundamentally different than what
we all get that, right? >> Instinct, her common sense.
Most of the time when people ask Candace for a source, she just
defers to her gut
>> Like this is not a source moment.
her common sense, but I don't think she knows what that phrase
means. Tyler is on videotape. She calls it fake based on nothing
and her audience will just believe her. >> What are we
to discern from all of this? I'll tell you I'll tell you my take
on this.
I think the person in the maroon
that's walking is different from the person that's walking up
the stairs. It's a gut thing. Okay. I don't know. No, but I know.
>> Sorry. Not to defend that whole thing where she's a
complete
>> I don't know now but I know I would discern that we
are looking just vibe again two different people would be my
thing two different people one of those people is definitely
individuals is definitely being protected >> her investigation
is based off vibes well vibes don't get convictions Candace at
one point she says she'll only stop with the conspiracies if
Erica Kirk tells her to >> okay so I want to be very clear
here
No one, and I mean absolutely no one, outside of my husband and
Erica Kirk, has the power to shut me up right now. >> Southern
Erica, asked for the conspiracy theorists to stop. >> But
when you go after my family,
my Turning Point USA family, my Charlie Kirk show family, when
you go after the people that I love, and you're making hundreds
and thousands of dollars every single episode because somehow
they're in on this.
No. And so my message to them is to >> Candace then does
a stream titled Erica tells me to stop. She watches Erica saying
she's not involved in her >> None of us
are involved in my husband's murder.
None of us.
Turning point USA
>> Candace then says she can't ignore her own common sense,
implying that Erica is playing a role in covering up Charlie's
murder. The problem is that you have people on social media who
are talking common sense and they don't understand
>> Okay, that that's like I just that doesn't work for
me. It doesn't work for me and it shouldn't work for you. >> But
when people bring it up, she backpedals too. Well, I never explicitly
said that. >> So Lily's identified it. The the Candace
Tucker pattern. Okay. I didn't say that.
I never said that. What are you insane? Are you out of your mind?
I want to say to first and foremost Glenn setting that question
up, I can't find to this day because this just feels to me to
be like the the ultimate straw man. Any commentator that has
explicitly accused Erica of Charlie Kirk >> at times I
feel like I'm watching a gender swapped Eric Carmen. >> I
looked through your stupid book. It's 540 pages of ripping on
Wendy and calling her a I do not directly say she's a Wendy Tester
has proven time and time again that she will do anything to pleasure
her. Whether it is the school football team or the janitors on
their break, Wendy spends her time as president on her knees
or on her back taking the old inn out for hours on end. You didn't
read the rest, dude.
>> Or does she? >> Or does she? >> See, that's
a question. I'm asking questions. I want to touch on
>> uh I would not be shocked depending on the season this
was produced in. This may be directly referencing Candace Owens
or Tucker Carlson, right? It might actually be directly referencing
them. I'm not even joking. They have been directly referencing
them like sorry I say directly like um like an homage kind of
thing. They literally did an homage to Charlie Kirk, but um like
that could easily be that although I think
>> yeah no it could be that same season. >> Or does
she does she >> see that's a question I'm asking >> I
WANT TO TOUCH ON Candace claiming France is going to she tweeted
I informed the people in the federal government and the White
House of the France and Israeli assassination plot and I'm willing
to provide full details as well as the name of the assassins
and international accounts in France and Canada. Oh, dude. That's
uh that is not Dude, this is an old ass episode. That's 2009.
That episode's 2009. Oh my god, that's [laughter] that's 17 years
old. >> For which money? >> Okay. No, more like more
like 18 years old. That that
>> that episode is an adult >> feels especially urgent,
right? Don't you feel a sense of urgency right now in the wake
of me having learned that France apparently paid for my assassination
and that the French Foreign Legion was apparently involved and
on the ground at UVU on the day of Charlie Kirk's assassination
>> And we should probably begin there. >> Candace,
if you have proof, why not just post the names yourself? I don't
know
>> So this is Oh, he's so close. He's so close. He's right
there to the sourcing argument. the s the sourcing problem, right?
She'll say, "Somebody told me this happened. Somebody who's in
a position to know told me this happened.
I've been I check I check this person's credentials. If they're
lying, they would be like, you know, it's crazy that they would
lie. They're a person with multiple connections. They're like
in this space. They know what they're talking about, right? And
they told me this happened." And and I I'm just going off of
what they said. >> Why she's doing this? I think it's because
the president of France is suing her because she won't stop saying
his wife has a >> They remember that one of your courageous
moves was to repeatedly tell the world that Bridget Macron is
a man. As you now know, >> as you now know, we had a $300,000
bet to charity about this cuz she's a woman is my view. >> She's
not a woman. >> Well, we're going to find out is the point
because it's going to court. They're suing you and when she proves
as she will that she's a woman cuz it's very easy to prove and
you lose that case then that she refuses for years. >> Yeah.
Why doesn't the first lady of France just post her coocher on
Twitter? Candace Owens the podcaster is the >> dude. The
best part is literally if Mcronone posted a video of her fully
clothed spinning around and like everything to prove it's not
AI and then dropped her pants and showed her fully on stream,
Candace would go, "I told you that she knows good people in plastic
surgery. I told you she knows people who do transplastic surgery."
It's like, dude, are you S
She literally couldn't do anything. There's nothing that Pie
Mcrone could do to change Candace's mind. Like, you could literally
have a camera on Bridget Mcronone while she gets like blood taken.
It gets spun in a centrifuge. They check her chromosomes. They're
all like X X chromosomes, okay? Like entirely.
And it just wouldn't matter. It literally wouldn't matter at
all. That centrifuge is compromised. Like it just it would not
matter. Anything you do can't prove Candace wrong. It may sound
like I'm being facitious when I say that, but it's actually what
Candace
>> We're going to find out for a blood test. We asked you
for some photos and you refused and everybody knows that we're
going to find out was not shot by Tyler Robinson on a rooftop.
>> And I think you has a I really want you to know
>> Mcronone has a >> Dude, Piers knows that he's
a total total scumbag, too. Piers knows exactly what she's going
to say when he brings her on. Piers isn't really trying to press
her. I feel like he almost breaks right here and laughs. >> Has
a penis. I I really wanted >> does not have a penis.
>> He's so close. He's so close to breaking and laughing
right here. He is so close. He is so close. He's trying so hard.
He is like biting his tongue, trying his hardest not to smile
or laugh. This You know exactly what you're doing, Piers.
No, she doesn't have a P at all. That's absurd for you to say.
Bridget Mcronone has opinions.
He's gonna get as much of this on camera as he can. >> Bridget
Mcronone has I'm sorry. >> No, man. This is accountability.
Is it three children? Did she get it removed? >> She had
three children. >> Yeah. You you you you can have adoptive
children. You can call somebody. But Breit Mcron, >> you
see, hold on. That that is exactly that's exactly how this would
go the whole time, right? You can have adoptive children. What
do you mean? You could totally have adoptive children. was born
a dude named John Michelle Tro. No. And I just feel I want you
to know that. I want you to know that Breijit Mcronone probably
stands peeing up. >> Now, this is going to court and Candace
will be
stands peeing up. She stands peeing up. >> But she's smart.
She's already setting up the narrative that the only way she
can lose is if federal corruption is at
>> Let's wait for the court case. Let's wait for the court
case. >> Okay, great. And you will be proven wrong again.
just federal corruption. >> This is what conspiracy theorists
do whenever they're proven wrong. They always shift the goalpost.
It's a forever moving target. There's always another explanation.
>> I am sorry that in this day and age there seems to be
such a shortage of testosterone that a woman has to be the person
that states the obvious, right? >> Her idea of obvious
is the opposite of obvious. Listen to how elaborate this is.
If you were one of the people online who believed for a single
second that it was even a remote possibility that I simply made
up a French assassination attempt heading into Thanksgiving week.
I don't know for like attention or something. I sat around and
I said, "hm, I'm just not getting enough attention."
Just this is her gaslighting voice. Okay. Whenever Candace is
speaking with this tone, she's just hardcore gaslighting people
just to know like the most the most concentrated powerful gaslighting
spell of all time. Like I would just make this up out of nowhere
for like attention. If you're one of the people who like possibly
thinks something like this, well, I'm here to tell you, >> how
can I start a global conversation about me? And then I came up
with this idea of creating fanfiction where I imagined myself
as the victim of a multinational state plot to murder me. Yeah.
If you thought that for a single second uh that it was for funsies
because I'm not busy or anything,
then you're just not sober. You're not paying attention to anything.
>> You're not >> You're crazy. You're You're like
out of your mind. Yeah, I shut the stove off. What are you Why
Why are you asking about the Of course I shut the stove off.
Are you kidding me? >> Not sober. The clip that she shows
that she's going to get is her own tweet. That's it. >> I
obviously tweeted exactly what I was informed. Okay, I'm going
to read that tweet to you and it's >> Oh, Willie, there's
such a good point here. There's such a good point. Please, Willie,
point out that her proof is not just a tweet. It is a tweet saying
she has a source that has told her this is happening and that
she she doesn't talk about that source but she always presents
this as like a thing that is that she was informed was happening
was apparently happening was allegedly >> it entirety
urgent two days ago I was contacted by a high
>> I'm somehow just realizing how many of her mannerisms
are adopted from Tucker well it's this way of speaking that grips
people right it does grip people and You can basically say whatever
you want and you sound authoritative and you're able to set questions
up in a way that people can't answer, right? So, you look smart
because you're stumping people. They don't actually know the
answer to your question. They like can't answer it easily, right?
Well, if if everything's fine here, then like why are there no
childhood pictures of Bridget Mcronone? If she's really a woman,
could we just get like childhood pictures? Are there really no
childhood pictures of Bridget Mcronone? That doesn't seem possible,
right? And then, yeah, I don't know if they're childhood pictures,
but obviously Bridget hasn't produced any. And it's like, well,
wait, that is weird. Hold on. That is weird, isn't it? And you
you do that, you seem smart. So, it's like a combination of seeming
smart to stupid people and yeah, just doing the intentionally
gaslighting when because she could do it to Willie. You go like,
"Wait, do you think I said that I knew I was getting assass?"
I said I had a source and I I literally said apparently this
is what's happening. Apparently this is what's >> Ranking
employee of the French government person claims the Mcron have
executed upon and paid for my assassination.
Yes, you read that correctly. More specifically, that the green
light was given to a small team in the national Gandarie intervention
group. I am told there is one Israeli that is on the assassination
squad and that plans were formalized. Candace is once again claiming
she has evidence while never showing anything. This video could
go on for another hour. She never stops. Candace tweeted, "They
have been signaling that a 9/11 style attack is coming the second
week of December. Save this tweet. It will age well." Nothing
happened and she never commented on this again. But she did have
a conversation with Piers Morgan and it 911ed my brain. Candace
says that she's not seen one piece of evidence that Tyler Robinson
shot Charlie Kirk. I haven't seen one piece of compelling evidence
that Tyler Robinson scaled the rooftops.
>> Oh, sorry. I cut my mic off there for a second. There
it is, though. Right. We We all see what she did there.
That she always adds a subjective standard to something. She
always adds like a cloud a cloudy standard. A standard that clouds
like definitive statements every single time. Apparently, this
is what's happening. And apparently that's what's happening.
It's been reported that this is what happen. Somebody I've been
told by a source close to X entity that this is what's happening.
I've been told by c this certain person, this certain source,
this anonymous person that this is happening. Well, I haven't
seen a single credible fact. I haven't seen a single credible
fact, a single credible piece of evidence, right? A single convincing
piece of evidence. And then she just gets to set the subjective
standard wherever she wants. So, she could say this is true and
then
it becomes an argument about what credible or convincing is instead
of actually about whether it's a reasonable opinion to have.
So hopefully Willie picks that up. That is that is another tactic
Candace uses that you could point out in a video would be very
intelligent would well sorry it' be like reasonably intelligent
be intelligent intelligent god intelligent be like second order
>> It says that she's not seen one piece of evidence that
Tyler Robinson shot Charlie Kirk. I haven't. >> And Candace
would crucify him for that, right? Because he doesn't actually
directly quote her.
He says
that she said she's not seen a single piece of evidence. She
didn't say that, right?
And those are definitively different statements. Those are wildly
different
>> In my brain, Candace says that she's not seen one piece
of evidence that Tyler Robinson shot Charlie Kirk. I haven't
seen one piece of compelling evidence that Tyler Robinson scaled
the rooftops like Spider-Man on a college campus that he didn't
go to.
>> I will say Willie is right to point out that she is
directly saying it like she is she is saying it in a way that
her entire audience will interpret it the same way he just did.
Actually, I just
[laughter] that's what happened to Willie. Willie Willie understands.
Okay, Willie is being caught up in Candace's spell already. It
literally just happened to him where it's like that is what they
hear is she said she's not seen a single piece of evidence. She
has seen a single piece of evidence. She has seen evidence. She
rejects that evidence. She says that evidence is not compelling
based on her gut.
It's like a different thing and but it gives her like positive
plausible deniability.
And I don't know. I think like while I would agree with Willie
Mack if you wanted to say but she's like clearly implying this.
She's clearly trying to say this without saying it. I would say
yeah absolutely she is. But you need to call it the tactic because
if you're unfortunately when you're trying to call people out
like this, you have to be like 10 times more accurate than them,
10 times better than them. If somebody's just willing to lie
like this to constantly manipulate, you have to be 10 times better
than them to actually score any points or else they'll just a
be able to infinitely like off like this. Uh and fired one shot,
a magic bullet shot uh in and Charlie Kirk.
I just I have not seen one piece of compelling evidence. In fact,
I've seen more compelling evidence to the >> No, you haven't.
She has no evidence showing the contrary. However, the evidence
that Tyler did Charlie is Tyler walking up the stairs to the
roof, him running and jumping off the roof, holding the gun,
him running out of the woods where the gun was later found. Him
limping because he hurt his leg when he jumped off the roof,
and him admitting
him running out of the woods where the gun was later found. Him
limping because >> maybe I don't know his leg when
>> if I'm not mistaken, that's him walking to the campus,
right? Am I crazy? I thought this was what him walking to the
campus before he'd gotten on the roof and that we thought this
was him
walking with like the gun barrel or something
This was him going back. Are you sure, Vanera? Cuz I could have
sworn this came out and they said it was him leaving or sorry,
going to the school. Hold on. Let's find let's figure it out
because I'm positive that I saw this framed as him going to the
school and people asking why he was limping implying he was limping
with the gun. But I it could have just been that it came out
too early that the FBI misidentified it early or that I read
a post that was just misinformation. I do want to see though
just in case.
We don't want to be incorrect if we're going to say it's a criticism.
Tyler Robinson limping
bit through neighborhood. Sure. Sure. Sure. the homeowner who
captured the suspect uh on surveillance camera is >> Charlie
Kirk is all his community has been talking about >> looked
at my camera and I first had seen the guy limping I thought oh
there's something wrong with that guy's leg I didn't think nothing
of it but then when my son went through the our our
um ABC4 spoke with the homeowner who captured the surveillance
footage of Tyler Robinson walking to school specifically the
footage showing him walking with a limp to the school.
Yeah, I don't know. I understand the compelling narrative that
that's him limping when he got back from the school, but this
is how it was reported. Now, that's not guaranteed, I guess,
just from ABC 4 here,
but
again, like I it's probably not even that tangible or important.
It kind of is. It kind of is when you're calling out somebody
for doing like misinformation, right? Uh
yeah. Anyway, it's it's fine.
I'm not even 100% sure cuz it seems like other people are convinced
otherwise. I'm guessing there's both versions of the story out
there and depending on like how you Google it or or what source
you look at, there might be someone's because it's a very compelling
narrative. Oh, he jumped off the roof and so now his legs [__]
up, right?
>> When he jumped off the roof and him admitting to doing
it to multiple people. None of that is evidence to you, but random
planes, random holes in the ground, any random person that emails
you, that's evidence. Okay, dude. Candace keeps saying that people
at Turning Point are complicit in Charlie. So, Piers presses
her on it. >> That that to me, even that seems like a part
of telling people not to to believe their own gut. Obviously,
for this to have been pulled off, there had to have been multiple
people involved. There had to have been people at turning point
that were complicit in having this happen. Now, who knows what
their motivations are. Doesn't mean maybe this person's like,
"Hey, I'm going to help." >> Hang [laughter] on. Okay,
let me stop you. Hang on. When you say obviously somebody at
Turning Point, you are accusing right now people that worked
with Charlie Kirk at >> news outlets and law enforcement
descriptions treat the neighborhood limping video footage as
from before the shooting, not after. CNN's coverage explicitly
describes the doorbell camera video showing Robinson's limp as
before the shooting and geolocates it to a nearby neighborhood.
TMZ and the New York Post likewise report the residential area
footage shows Robinson walking towards Utah Valley University
hours before he allegedly shot Charlie Kirk.
Yeah, I don't know. It's just kind of important like random factual
information that when you're talking about somebody who isn't
diligent, who doesn't get facts correct, probably an important
thing to get right. You know, >> the company he built,
which is now run by his widow, you are directly accusing people
in that company of being complicit in his murder. Right.
I want I want to just be very clear connecting that dot. >> She's
not clear at all. She just rambles about JFK before claiming
that Charlie was over money. >> Common sense inquiry is
was there a financial motive for this person to be dead. Okay,
this is like Sherlock Holmes >> What was the financial
incentive to kill this YouTuber? Like for who? I can only think
of Erica because she's now running the company. But Candace never
explains. She just says >> I mean the I like I don't agree
with it. The financial incentive narrative is Israel wanted to
pay for Charlie to stay on their side. Israel knew Charlie was
going to leave their side. So Israel Charlie Kirk, so one of
their most powerful and like powerful and strong advocates wasn't
going to flip on them. Now I don't believe any of that cuz Charlie
Kirk was the strongest golem in the Israeli arsenal. All right,
I don't believe that for a second, but that is like a narrative
that could possibly explain some motive to kill him if you were
just hypothesizing. If you wanted, if you had no facts and you
just wanted to start looking at somebody, then that's a narrative
you could hypo that is possible. Doesn't really mean >> As
it's common sense, it declares victory. This >> is what
I mean when I say that the public no longer trusts the media
because you're acting us to be stupid and we don't want to do
that. We actually don't want to pretend that we're clinical idiots.
>> Gandis, I'm realizing you're not pretending. Gandice
never answers Piers's question. So, we ask again, who at Turning
Point is complicit in >> I want to get to the reality of
what you're actually saying. So when you say that somebody at
Turning Point USA, Charlie's company was complicit in his murder,
who >> who was?
>> I believe that there were multiple people who at Turning
Point who are, as I have said many times, my exact words are
they are engaged in a cover up of what happened to Charlie on
that day. >> No, but who was involved in his murder?
>> I I didn't say that they murdered >> You said
that people at Turning Point were complicit in his murder. No,
>> you literally just said they were >> Obviously,
for this to have been pulled off. There had to have been multiple
people involved. There had to have been people at Turning Point
that were complicit in having this happen. >> Piers presses
her on this. She denies reality. She's got the memory of a goldfish
appar. >> That never happened. Are you Are you insane?
I never said that.
>> no. I My exact sentence that I said was that there were
people at Turning Point who are engaged in a coverup.
>> I believe thoroughly. >> Candace, you didn't say
that. She then says something even crazier. >> Anybody
at Turning Point, did anybody at Turning Point in your opinion
know that Charlie Kurt was going to be murdered?
>> There is specifically two people at Turning Point USA
and I have communicated that information to Erica and Justin
Strife that I would not be surprised if they had fornowledge
of Charlie Kirk being assassinated. But you have any evidence?
>> I'm not going to name I I I am not going to name those
people, okay? because it's not right for me to name those people
until I know for a fact that they did. But she has actually named
a Turning Point USA employee before. So Piers asks her about
him and she doubles down. >> Do you believe Mikey McCoy
had any prior knowledge of Charlie's murder? >> I can't
say that he had prior knowledge of of the murder unless I have
something concrete. I can't say anything about prior knowledge.
What I can say is what happened on that day. Mikey's behavior
is weird on that day. I find it weird, like I said in the podcast
yesterday, that what has been communicated to the public is like
he called Erica
>> Do you see that she's very careful about making like
direct claims? That's what I'm talking about is like if somebody
was just dumb. I feel like she would trip and [__]
this up a lot. She's very good about making sure she's saying,
"Well, I believe, you know, common sense dictates that somebody
must have been complicit there. Somebody must have been involved."
She doesn't say who it is. She doesn't say why they're there.
It's like a whole bunch of [__] where if she was
just a total I do believe she'd slip up here a lot more than
she does. When she does slip up, it's like notable >> instantly.
First thing he did was call in Erica instantly. And that's actually
the calls.
Show that he didn't call Erica >> So this guy Mikey is
getting roped into Charlie because he said that he instantly
called Erica after Charlie was shot. Candice constantly calls
Mikey a liar for this. I do believe that Mikey McCoy should have
to answer for who he had on the phone right when the shot went
off. So yeah, his father, his own father that surprised me the
most about these call logs is I certainly feel that we were given
the impression over. By the way, the reason so Mikey McCoy said
he talked to Erica first. The thing he didn't want to say, which
is what obviously happened, was I was up. I was mentally. I called
people who comforted me. I called I worried about myself before
I worried about Erica.
And that's embarrassing. So, I just said I called Erica first.
That I knew that this guy had a wife. I knew that his wife needed
to know. But instead of actually calling his wife first, I called
my wife cuz I needed to like vent and be okay. That's He didn't
want to say that. It's very obvious what happened there, right?
Or he might have even gone, "I don't even know what I'm going
to do. I don't know what's going dude. My my meal ticket is gone."
It could have been something along those lines, not that explicit,
like I don't know what's going to happen with Turning Point.
I don't know what's going to happen with my job. I don't know
what's going to happen with anything. Could have been anything,
right? But of course, he'd say, "Well, no, I called Erica cuz
that's the right thing to do. People lie to make themselves look
better." >> Over and over again that the first >> by
the way, that is the most that is the most obvious element of
human behavior. That is the most obvious explanation of human
behavior in this case, why he would have called those people
first. I don't know why Candace doesn't just go with AAM's razor
here, right? Aams razor isn't, oh, they helped in a cover up.
Aams razor is, oh, these people didn't want to make themselves
look bad, so they made statements that didn't make them look
bad.
>> Mikey called was Erica, right? He called Erica. He was
We were told this by many people also that he was he trained
like like he almost like went to a >> Wait, why the [__]
did that get censored? What got censored? We were given the impression
over and over and over again >> that the first person Mikey
called was
>> right? He called Erica. He was we were told this by
many people also that he was he trained like like he almost like
went to a camp and trained and Charlie was like 1 2 3 go and
like fast 1 2 3 go. That's why he walked away go and just told
him this is what the first thing you do is. >> Well, he
didn't do that. >> Yeah. You want to know what Mikey actually
did first? He called his wife and then he called
>> Fantab, I don't see the chat censored in my chat overlay.
So, I just I see your your chat comes through on my chat overlay.
So, I I never see the >> 3 minutes later. Wow, what an
evil liar. >> Well, he didn't do that. Actually, the first
person he called was his wife. He called Elizabeth McCoy. Um,
and then he stayed on the phone with his wife for 10 minutes.
And during those 10 minutes, he three-wayed
Erica 3 minutes after the shot went off. And then he three-ways
his father, >> accusing him of his friend because he said
the word instantly when in reality it was 3 minutes later. Between
the word instantly and the word vehicle, Candace has become the
dictionary police. >> What are you suggesting about this
guy?
>> As you know, when you got a massive show that Blake
Nef actually about what happened on that day. >> But here's
the problem, Candace. You have a massive platform as you know
millions and millions of people hang on your every word. When
you devote a large part of an entire episode to the strange behavior
of Charlie Kirk's chief of staff, you are putting a target on
the guy's back, you're inferring has something to do with this
or something to do with some cover up or whatever it is you're
inferring. You know what you're doing when you do that. >> I
I am not going to be emotionally conditioned to believe that
asking questions when we aren't getting any answers is the crime
itself. The crime was when Charlie got shot in the neck. >> it's
such an evil thing to put on someone. She can't be this stupid.
She's being malicious. Look at all of the intentional lying she's
done. She cuts the video short of Tyler Robinson saying the word
vehicle. She lies about the flights of the Egyptian planes. She
says there's no evidence of Tyler shooting Charlie when he's
the only person caught on video with a gun. He blamed Charlie's
friends. Blame Charlie's wife. All >> Well, I mean, I'm
sorry. Like
let's say if you work from the point of view that there was a
conspiracy here, there is technically nothing that proves this
is Tyler Robinson,
right? We don't know that that's Tyler Robinson. We don't see
Tyler Robinson climb up the thing, right? As far as I know, I
don't recall seeing Tyler Robinson like climb up onto the roof.
We don't see something that connects him in that way. There's
not proof. It like I don't think it's there. Just if this was
actually something that was getting covered up, it would just
be covered up better. I assume, right? I assume this footage
basically would >> He's the only person caught on video
with a gun. He blamed Charlie's friends, blamed Charlie's wife,
all without showing a single source. Weaponized her friendship
with Charlie to go after them. Weaponized her viewers religion
by saying Charlie talked to her in a dream or God sent her evidence
in an email. People want there to be a more exciting answer to
Charlie Kirk's murder. >> This feels to me like a conspiracy.
And am I emotionally invested in this? Yes.
Somebody said something to >> There's footage of him walking
up some stairs. There's footage. He was definitely there that
day. Evil Johnny Bravo. Like, there's no reason to believe he
wasn't the guy who pulled the trigger. He was there that day.
He confessed to doing it, right?
Uh he had a gun that looks like the gun that they said they found
in the woods. It like when they followed the trail of the guy
in the video, like it would have to be the FBI explicitly in
on this cover up, trying to cover it up, trying to get somebody
out who was involved, right? You'd have to have like the a ton
of people in the FBI. Totally complicit in this. It's completely
unbelievable. There's no reason to believe that this isn't the
case. I'm just saying with those videos, you could say, "Okay,
well, that's not that's not Tyler Robinson on the roof. He's
a fall guy."
>> Oh, you're unstable. Yeah. You know what? You're right.
I
>> um This isn't true. This isn't true, J. Just so you
know, that that explicitly I I totally disagree with. Um, Charlie
Kirk wasn't worth by a government. That's totally wrong. Charlie
Kirk was somebody incredibly powerful, incredibly influential
in the politics of the most important, powerful, influential
country on the planet Earth.
Um, there would be political reasons you would want to go after
him. Like if he was against you on some political issue, there
is reason that you could expect him to somebody to want him dead.
Like I'm not joking, that could rise to the level of governments.
I don't think that happened here. I don't think there's anybody
he he was an incredibly powerful person. When Willie calls him
a YouTuber, when people call him a YouTuber, just a streamer,
just a Tik Tocker, that's not true. That he was one of the most
in influential figures in all of American politics.
That it's like his political influence cannot be understated.
It was
massive. So I I don't but I'm I'm we're like all this is to say
that there are reason I'm more or less just kind of pointing
out the reasons that conspiracy works for people because it's
not quite as like it's not always as insane as people say, right?
But it's I'm only doing that to say this is basically how people
can be led to believe it. It's not to lend credence to it. The
conspiracy isn't real in my opinion. Yeah, exactly. Evil Johnny
Bravo. Like people are involved. Like we we literally have a
ton of evidence that other countries are involved in America's
politics in trying to shape America's politics going forward.
There's just tons of there's tons of indicators of this.
So there's no reason to believe that if Charlie was, you know,
if Charlie was like one of the biggest hawks against a certain
country, like if like literally
Iran just off the top of my dome, wouldn't Iran want this guy
dead? This guy's like one of the most powerful Zionist figures.
He gets everybody to stay on the Zionist train in American politics.
He holds down anti-Zionist influencers,
right?
I could I could come up with a solid reason Iran would just be
like, "Here's 5 million bucks to Charlie Kirk."
Pretty sure like just But I don't think that happened. That doesn't
mean I could say that it happened. It's just like off the top
of my dome. Yeah, Iran probably wants this guy dead.
Certainly if Iran could see the future, see how it kind of like
snowballed into this massive anti-ionist movement on the right,
Iran would pull that trigger
>> I have been destabilized by watching Charlie Kirk catch
a bullet in his neck and then >> sorry again. This is all
to say while this is true, every country could have wanted let's
like just because it's possible doesn't mean it happened or that
you should even lend credence or lend like any of your brain's
processing time to that idea. Right? You wait for something to
flag that idea for you before you actually give it any processing
time. Otherwise, you're just stuck spiraling on that could possibly
happen for the rest of your life. It's >> and being gaslit
and told nothing to see here. We've got people all around him
that are telling little lies. I don't like this. >> Like
a secret global cabal. Or maybe it's the boring answer in Charlie's
content ped off a dude who had a transgirlfriend. Andy shot Charlie
at a school. School shootings happen all the time. In fact, a
school shooting at Evergreen High School happened the same day
Charlie was shot. Or maybe the Egyptian planes did that one.
>> Wait, who did I bet? There was somebody I bet and they
ended up paying me like 50 bucks or 25 bucks for this. Oh, it
was um he's got that stupid name. It wasn't. It was somebody
else. They have a stupid stupid like name like a fart name, a
butt name, something like that. Buttsniff. It was Buttsniff.
I bet it was Buttniff.
That's who I bet. Yeah.
Yeah, that guy got rolled. A whole bunch of lefties got rolled
on that. Betting on um if he was a groper or if he was like trans
ail like somehow like trans
Yeah,
Lil Bros got rolled on that one. >> One, too. I haven't
heard Candace's opinion on that one yet. Her viewership kind
of confuses me because they aren't even good conspiracy. She
doesn't even have circumstantial level evidence. >> Oh,
does her viewership really confuse
Oh, that's shocking. That's why that's why this video like I
knew this video would suck because Willy's not capable of like
second order thinking. So he he's just completely incapable of
conceiving why people would like Candace, why they would like
the content. You just can't do it. There's no theory of mind
there. It's very very I I knew this video would be funny for
me. I'm sure some people will like it though.
I of course will openly say I dislike it on the stream. Okay.
This guy, he's a [__] loser.
That's why he's less than ADIQ. Yeah. Well, yeah, conditional
hypotheticals do do baffle this person. Anyway, Candace Mogs
him. Well, I I don't disagree that with most of the like base
level analysis of Candace lying, I don't really disagree. It's
like there are actually interesting narratives here about Candace
Owens that you can go into that are like fun to pull apart, but
not for Will >> for the things she says. Flat-earthers
have more evidence than she does. Candace needs to be ritually
humiliated for what she's doing, and I will continue to do that
in part two. So, subscribe to the channel and thank you Aura
for sponsoring this video. Shout out to the homies over on Patreon.
>> Hopefully hopefully Willie like watches this uh segment
when it comes out. I got really good ideas for how you can make
number two like part two really good. Okay, you just go back
and listen to some of the criticisms.
Anyway, I think that is it for us guys.
That was fun. Right at the end of the stream, we get got over
to eight hours. Let's go. Another eight hour stream in in the
books under the belts. Who we got online? We got Res's online.
Probably should resi a raid. Oh, wait. Resi just ended. GG.
Resi just ended.
Uh, I could just shoot you guys. Looks like Crisp is watching
movies.
I'm not going to I'm not going to endorse Chris watching movies
on stream. I don't know if I can do that, man.
I don't know if I can do that, dog. I love I don't mind Chris,
but dude, you got to do your own content. You got to make streaming
work if you're going to stream, buddy.
Malik is live. I'm not going to raid anybody. [__]
it. Nick is live. Yeah, I'm not going to raid anybody. I'm just
going to go off.
All right. Okay. We'll talk to you guys later. Nah, I'm not going
to raid Nick. You guys can go watch Nick if you want, but Nick's
not even live, I don't think. It's just like a bunch of people.
It's like a multicam stream. All right.
So, I'll talk to you guys later. Be back tomorrow. Have a good
night. See you later, everybody. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye.